oh alright and we are live welcome to
the iron ore podcast episode number 85
and it's another glorious Sunday we are
back at the round table and the Lord's
Day I'm extremely excited about a
special guest and we've got spider-man
dominating NPD Red Dead Redemption 2
impressions crackdown 3 online
destruction
Banjo Kazooie news game past a pc and x
cloud controllers to discuss so we're
gonna get right into it
I wanted to do some Lord it was not only
considered a true friend to the realm
but from the very beginning has always
demonstrated the utmost passion for
gaming both past and present this Lord
exemplifies the epitome of balanced
perspective we'll call our hypocrisy of
seen yet at the same time is never
afraid to challenge his own opinions on
the latest gaming topics introducing the
host and creator of the Jay Fonzarelli
YouTube channel everyone's favorite
podcast panelists and captain neutral
himself fellow combat sport fair fellow
retro gamer and the Lord who is arrived
on horseback to remind everyone why read
dead 2 is to go to 2018 making his
return into the realm of the Lords my
main Lord
Jake Fonzarelli how you doing sir thank
you for that great intro and anytime
somebody says retro gamer they're really
saying they're really saying old that
[Laughter]
those arthritic fingers playing these
[Laughter]
great to have you long overdue to have
you back it's pretty well we got a lot
of games discuss right yeah definitely
definitely a lot of games and
man I've been putting in that time I
read dad will get today get into that
you already know and you know we have
the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords of the round here at the
round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the howl of the young
okay school bad there you got a lot of
stuff chat is just lovely
you have a touch potentially that red
[Laughter]
thing and then I'm probably getting off
because I don't feel good alright
alright and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Damas
mister offline profile Illuminati and
Lord patreon of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign I daughter bleeding right
now
[Laughter]
retired Oh king is a fool I can't before
we shoot it off the king I'm a couple of
housekeeping notes really quickly first
off patreon guys yes so patreon has
decided to move away from language that
speaks about any sort of giveaways or
anything like that apparently they've
been a few patreon um yeah that have
been a less than savory shall we say and
people who have not been receiving what
they've been promised like you know here
at iron Lords podcast so long as the
palm is greased you always get I always
get what you're promised it you always
get it apparently we had a few bad
apples that ruined it for everyone on
patreon so we had to remove all the
language indicating what you would be
getting at various tiers so don't fret
it's all still there we're still doing
it just the same way we just have to
figure out how to change that language
on the patreon itself right now it seems
like the tiers have no differentiation
so okay as soon as we can figure that
out with patreon
it'll be changed so anybody new coming
to the fold same thing if you guys see
anybody question like what the heck is
this just let them know everything is
still in place giveaways monthly stuff
is still in place um second big shout
out to our gleam Red Dead Redemption -
winner yes my old tartufo in Portugal
this should be finally finished
downloading red dead rats to him um
enjoy the game secondly Lords as a big
thank you to all you guys being here
every single week in the chat listening
to the show we have a Red Dead 2 code to
give away today on the lookout it's for
PlayStation to be on the lookout in the
chat we're gonna do make the - OH
it contains exactly five pixels for its
appearance is gonna be in the chat we're
gonna do try to do some fun stuff to see
who gets it in the chat so as a big
thank you to you guys for being here all
the time
well that's that all right and of course
we have I don't even know who I can't
even call you they're the incredible the
amazing dressed me as my given name the
XS spider-man game the best nothing less
to their premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement I am
doing fantastic citizen you know I don't
give a dang about MPD's but this is what
everyday that I care about to a bit a
beautiful bit and I told you when I win
baby the king wins big its grand DC will
pause no it's so crazy that it is the
craziest selling game in PlayStation
history yes somebody said last week they
said um I have a bag that authority true
that you go be into pushes it look like
the Limpy DS and got my man sick Oh
[Laughter]
and then I played some Tekken Rob
because I was forced to buy a second on
that system to play hip hop and you know
oh my god that Tekken is so amazing it
just took me back so when we was playing
um I play some destiny I play some
horizon um I'm trying to like you know
flesh out all my back let's see my back
leg with a PlayStation 4 small so just
you know like knock all that stuff out
but um oh I had to address a fraud stuff
run ler yeah it was sad this week I felt
I felt disheartened by what our
community is becoming and what I didn't
like is I have friends this week they
got into a disagreement and then you had
hanger-ons that were amping the
situation up that don't know these
individuals and all these individuals in
their own right are good men yes okay
and these are men not no little boys
these are men all right and they they
have always all of all three of them
have always treated me as a man and has
has welcomed me and have been very very
good you know good guys to me all right
and um I have nothing but kind words to
say about all individuals involved what
I didn't like was the vitriol that was
thrown at individuals from either side
from the hanger-ons that don't know
these people and as a sir baited a
situation that didn't need to be
exacerbated listen guys um your own a
piece of plastic you didn't do anything
special you went to the store you
purchase a piece of plastic and to
denigrate and disrespect people who
don't have the financial stability to
purchase multiple pieces of plastics and
to game everywhere
that shows your character alright um I'm
pretty sure that everyone regardless of
their financial situation will love to
gain everywhere possible if their gamer
so to disrespect someone because they
financially are not able to have the
same exact thing that you are that's
wrong yep alright and you didn't do
anything special so all this red versus
blue there's no such thing as red versus
blue you purchase a piece of plastic
they work for you because you're buying
games and you put money in their pocket
alright so you are employing these
companies all right you're employing
Sony Nintendo Microsoft any other gaming
system that you choose to game one you
are employing these guys they actually
work for you so I'm sitting there
worrying about numbers like you wanna
dock
you don't want stock in the company
sitting there talking about who sold
what and what has what pixels and what
that doesn't matter when you're gaming
we all share the same love so for people
to sit here and continue to say stuff
like Sony and Nintendo sucks and
Microsoft sucks and okay fine if you
feel that way but you don't have to go
after somebody else because of the
financial choices alright um there's a
piece of plastic guys man just keep it
100 percent gaming because a friend of
mine got banned this week he said
something that was wrong and I'm not
taking any sides in any of this I just
want you to understand that I respect
everybody involved I'm not taking any
one side but what I'm staying is a
conversation could have been had back
door to that could have stopped all of
this before it even know that it was and
hanger-ons people that don't know these
people at all assassinated it and turned
it into something that should have never
been factored and killed that well said
we all know the parties involved even
get into specifics but you know at the
end of the day it's about gaming it's
about plastic boxes no one holds any
stock I'm not couldn't even sell anybody
can you kill that so it's just like look
at the end of the day keep it gaming all
away 100 games in and let's have fun out
here
we got jokes and funny stuff on the
Lord's Day today so we would get your
mind off the negativity but of course
you know it is I Lord Cognito here
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so for me
yeah just bring on just art you know
right there last night we've got a
couple hours in maybe five to six we'll
get into that definitely - festival de
los been doing that and then I got my
man j+ builders i gotta talk a little
bit about that hold the trade deal that
went through huh and I'm glad you
brought it up because you know he's not
afraid and there's history glad Fonz
here because he's a good fan friend of
Mighty Mouse Demetrius Johnson and then
he's going to educate me on Ben Askren
who the UFC just received so again UFC
and One Championship have been the
first-ever at least I know Trey so tell
me what's going on here fine what's
going on we all know Demetrius Johnson
is the man that has been the the
flyweight champ for so long he he just
recently got defeated by split decision
by Henry cejudo in the UFC but forever
people were talking about how they
wanted to see Demetrius Johnson fight
better talent because in the flyweight
division I mean he was running through
all them people I mean he even beats a
hoot oh the last time they fought and
and this last fight was questionable as
well yes I don't think so who'd oh
really you know they say you have to
beat the champ well you know that it was
debatable he took him down and laid on
him a lot so you know it's it's MMA I
know it's it's something they do but so
there was a lot of Demetrius Johnson
felt like he was always being picked on
in the UFC he felt like that that
pressure to move up was always there and
he didn't like hearing it he wanted an
even camp is in the flyweight division
and stayed in Juba forever
pretty much so he wasn't hearing that
for four years now and and everybody was
screaming move up move up nobody wants
little guys fight and all this stuff I
personally love Demetrius Johnson I
think that
I think he's one of the best fighters to
ever fight in mixed martial arts sees
he's amazing to watch he's very
well-rounded he does some incredible
things in the cage but I myself wanted
to see him fight better competition I
want to move up and fight people like TJ
TJ Dillashaw yes I want to see you just
wouldn't do it
so this trade is is more interesting
than just on the level of them wanting
to get some money for him because he
wouldn't move up you're looking at a guy
over across the pond did Ben Askren and
when I say crest upon that this whole
one Hep C organization they're they're
based out of Asia and they do their
fights over there mostly and they have a
lot of fighters from the US that fight
over there and Ben Askren was one of
those guys that came from
Bellator yes and in Bellator I used to
watch him back then he was very very
dominant he's the guy he's undefeated
yeah he's 89 oh wow he's basically a
very dominant wrestler that honestly
he's he's a lot like khabib and I have
to mention khabib here because I think
this has something to do with them going
to pass my speculation is that they want
another guy who's just as talented in
that realm as khabib nurmagomedov and
they want to bring him over to
potentially fight cabina and nobody's
saying it really anything about this but
oh speculation this is this is something
I think that they're putting in to do
because hearing Ben Askren talk over the
years he wanted nothing to do with the
UFC growing white himself wanting wanted
nothing to do with Ben Askren yes
because Dana White this is where Dana
white shows that his his lack like the
heat look he's not stupid when it comes
to the mixed martial arts game but
sometimes he is in my opinion like this
doesn't get all the different facets of
mixed martial arts and you know
wrestling is a very big big law yeah
and a lot of these dudes that take
others down and won't let them get back
up
it's Dana White has a problem with that
and he wants to see people stand and
bang it seems like more often and often
than not yeah because of the appealing
that like he I know you go on and that's
country but you nailed it because
unfortunately you know the wrestler
style sometimes it's not the more flashy
style but it's the most offensive
struggles he struggles with that you
know I'm saying and I think in times he
likes that more the boxing you know he
likes to watch the boxing go on because
that actually will get the casual in you
know yeah that that's his thing when I
first started watching UFC myself back
in the day we're going back to UFC one
you know when they just four hundred
pounders and again so it was all just
free-for-all stuff but as time went on
they you know they got sanctioned they
were creating a sport in itself they
were actually developing this whole MMA
thing you know where all these sports
were intertwining and people were really
getting involved in different facets of
the sport and and the cool thing about
it was is that once I got in and got
past the whole oh they're not just
standing and banging I was starting to
learn what the whole time all around you
know the ground game I was starting to
learn oh he's trying to go for a Kimura
oh he's trying to go for a rear-naked
choke oh he's trying to go for a
triangle you know I started to learn
this stuff by just watching and people
do get sucked in after a while and go
wow you know this is amazing this ground
work is is awesome to watch the
defensive moves and all this it really
becomes entertaining to you so you know
with Ben Askren he's a guy like
nurmagomedov that likes to take people
down and just beat him you know he likes
to just rain down and they say he he
could be a threat [ __ ] be like that I
wouldn't we said that there's no doubt
that asking would wash kabhi but I'm
like whoa I've heard about this guy man
here's the thing
if you look at his record though I will
say that the one negative thing is he
hasn't fought a lot of known guys and
really hasn't fought a lot of known guys
said the biggest guy he's fought is a
Douglas Lima which was a two-time
champion Bellator which is not saying
much per se but he is a decent fighter
he's really good he could make it in the
UFC and do and do pretty well but the
way he washes these guys the way he
takes them down and won't let him up
like he's real bonds let me get the gist
of this the deal is they got rid of your
sea gave up Mighty Mouse yeah yeah all
right so they gave up Mighty Mouse for
this possible opponent for Hobby right
yeah all right so what do you what do
you feel that um because I I believe
Dana already concedes the fact that he
doesn't want to put in his cash cow to
get further damage right man I mean no
seriously because I didn't really think
that Conor was actually ready from his
first fight back his hubris was too much
to take that type of fight from active
fighter that of that magnitude probably
once-in-a-generation Thai fighter to put
him in there with him and we saw the
results I don't care what kind of did
the first round it was pretty much more
of what could be wanted to do that's
what happened so now that you say that
they're bringing over this fighter who
is an active fighter and maybe his
resume doesn't speak to the language
that may might appeal to certain people
but you saying that he might pair up
well with Habib and and as far as
grappling he needs no because I don't
know about do so funny straight up what
do you come a hundred percent yes Wow I
think he's a much better wrestler than
could be I think I I think that that the
guy I've seen him take too many people
down and they did not get back up okay
when I saw before I watched his last
seven fights and I saw a complete
Olympic level I mean because because
in you know I've I've been warned tear
though don't get it twisted Tony
Ferguson stills gonna have that next
shot because and he deserves it Ferguson
by all you know account is the guy that
can has the tools to be to be he not I
mean the guy is amazing he's very well
rounded great on on his back so if if
khabib does take him down it's not over
for him
gotcha he has a lot of tools to actually
stop could be from the bottom so uh but
here's the thing Ben Askren been
watching him for many years and and this
is a guy that I've been hoping that he
would get to the UFC one day and fight
some elite talent because I've always
thought he's got it I'm not the only one
who said this there's a lot of people
within the community that's been pushing
for this for many years Joe Rogan is one
of them as well however Dana White I
think this deal has nothing to do with
Dana White at the end of the day because
Dana White hates Ben Askren right mine
despises Ben asked right they've had B's
I think this new company that's taken
over the UFC this is more of their idea
ah nothing to do with Dana White but you
know it's very interesting at being the
first big trade in mixed never did
Demetrius Johnson though I am very sad
to see him go like I said I like
watching him unfortunately for the
pay-per-view draw it just wasn't there
for him fair enough some great
assessment was happy he's on Twitter
posted like Grady to creep out I saw his
Twitter he's he seemed excited you know
I think I've heard he already has a
relationship with the president of one
chimp they've had like they they go back
so the vibe I'm getting is that he just
he's been feeling disrespected as one of
the most dominant champions you know I
think Dana disrespects a lot of the
fighters in
the sense that well we all know that the
purse strings aren't as big as they
should be for these are fighters that I
Adeem NFL type fighters well you know
because they're not for long you know
they're very short their career is
actually shorter than any boxer that you
can bring up any other fighters that you
can bring up wrestlers and stuff like
that so these guys I think should be
getting paid bigger bang for the buck as
it goes along I'm hoping that this new
company that's purchased the UFC will
start implementing those purses to be
distributed in a fashion that doesn't
just reward the top earners and it
rewards the arm too under cards as well
because if you look at these guys purses
they purses are $5,000 that's not enough
to run a camp you understand and and you
tell me somebody okay and you wondering
why these guys is fighting this month
and he's on the next card the next month
or he's doing a show here it's because
they're getting paid our pins
and if the end if they can't act like
you know like some of the other guys
this button to get pushed to the side
like tyron woodley on that I don't like
the the treatment of a champion and in a
way that he's not pleasing to the
promoter in that sense and he's actively
disrespecting his champion worn away
through I mean even trying to give him
short ends of the purse strings you know
so I mean I can go on about what I don't
like what the practices but I do hope
that this this new guy I please send it
to me how fans in the link so I can
watch his fights because I'm trying to
learn like because I still call it a a
bare naked choke
the right way and I'm like no but it's
the think I would rather not it'd be
called Lord addict has been waiting
patiently so yeah man just real quick so
I just want to do I know I on which what
did the state of the what's called the
giveaway so we know we got that coming
you know I just want to also double down
we actually have on new life coming our
Lords of the hollow and the feast is
live so on the iron Lords store so you
know get you get that pumpkin and sweet
potatoes you know say that that sweet
potato orange ready for Halloween and
you got those various turkey gray
assortment so I'm gonna put that link in
the description as well so make sure you
guys head out over there we got like I
said a little holiday line something fun
and we actually have a ton more options
so if you click in there it's not just
the orange it's just not just the gray
it's also going to be other colors other
styles we got the socks we got a whole
bunch of things going man please check
that out
get yourself a part of the Horde is fire
man a lot of people show me what they
got the hoodies are moving out here
winter's coming so neutral you know
saying you get that Halloween edition
lord of the hollows ended grant don't
let no White Walkers and Lords Fonz
already kind of if you have if you
haven't living under a rock you haven't
followed ones we've done Lord finds his
ILP gaming history ILP number 47 so go
in the backlog to check that out a man
has a tremendous history this is not his
first rodeo here on the island Lord
round table but actually the realm but
need to know two things look like what
you've been playing as far as right now
surprise surprise I think I don't know
what that is and you also want to give
us our top 5 your top 5 revised right
are you good you
solid with the last time you when I was
here the last time you caught me with
that question and I was thinking about
the thousands of games that I played
since what am I gonna draw out of my hat
right yeah I totally botched that up I
think of the ones to put in order but I
got them today I need to put it out
there
let's go clarity all right number five
would be Mass Effect 2 ever that series
is amazing
yes except for that last one that ones
in the bushes then of course number four
you got Final Fantasy 7 mm-hmm one of my
all-time number three
I have halo combat Evolved an amazing
amazing game number two a lot of people
aren't gonna like my top two but hey
it's my top two let's go Last of Us
favorite game ever loved the story but
the emotion that I have to this game the
emotional tie yes number one Red Dead
Redemption all-time favorite game I you
know I've never played a game a second
time I played Red Dead Redemption three
times I had a whole X as well because
it's beautiful on the man a wonderful
story anyway that's my top 5 do a
beautiful list first of all at Alice's
fantastic tough that's a tough list
right there to beat me salute glad you
revised it so this way we got ultimate
clarity so we gonna move on and last
week's poll results are in people have
spoken
the question in reference to both the
negative and positive testimonials
regarding current conditions at Rockstar
Studios what statement closely
represents your sentiments regarding
game released deadline environments the
winner at 44% of the vote is the crunch
is only an issue if there is no OT or
compensation group
coming in at second at 29% was the no
one is forced to do anything in regard
to employment crunch is a choice group
at third place at 17% which the
companies will coerce you these
companies will call you into extreme
hours crunch he's wrong group and at
last place at 10 percent was the I don't
care if red they don't release on time
I'm gonna crunch the studio crew all the
Lord you participated last week for Lord
saw what do you think about this I mean
I said it last week that to me you know
if there are conditions that are not
agreeable to you at your job you need to
walk away you need to try to fix this
first and if that is not something
that's that's feasible then you need to
walk away for your own sanity
I'm not staying any place that's making
me unhappy um that said you know yeah
when you're a salaried salaried employee
and you're an at-will employee which is
like 90 percent of employees and in the
country yeah you're gonna be put in
position sometimes word you're gonna be
asked to work or quote-unquote forced to
work more hours for the same pay and
that again there are things that need to
change in industry as a whole not just
the gaming industry these are things
that are not unique to the gaming
industry that that's something that
needs to change it's not fair that you
get paid a flat rate salary and then the
hours you put in our double of somebody
who's on the clock right it doesn't make
sense that's what we got man enough owns
you how did you feel real quick as I
know this is a big topic for you as well
I feel a lot like solve here and I also
feel that that I need to say that these
companies do also disclose that as well
before you get hired on they usually
take look is the expected a lot no there
you're gonna be expected to stay here
some days many hours I know they did it
with my company they do it with that
kind of stuff I'm not saying it's fair
necessarily I'm not saying that it's
people work hundred plus hours believe
me when I've done that it sucks it's
terrible quality of life but this is not
a new thing to the gaming industry this
is known you know that's how I feel
alright so we are going
to get into what we are here for
obviously we know um spotty has
dominated NPD fell faster than God of
War I'm gonna give it to you about what
frame it we give it the Lord King let's
set the stage obviously with the NPD
results Lord's obviously Spider Man is
the obvious standout success from
September despite launching only
exclusively for a ps4 it outperformed
every other multi plan released for the
month
that is crazy from a historical
perspective corner map piscatella our
good friend on the round nine PD if the
best selling game of September achieved
the highest launch month dollar sales
for any PlayStation exclusive in history
and is the seventh launch largest launch
ever achieved by any game on the
PlayStation platform and then basically
how he created it he also said that from
basically from their launch month their
sales of this spider-man was 37 percent
higher than the combined launch launch
month sales of every spider bear Gabe
ever release combined that is insane
obviously this was a point of contention
for many months we know this is the very
first battle between Lord King on Attock
and Bethany is here so Lord King the
floor is yours and they will get addict
ready let me do this bend the knee thing
so I can go back to my PC Lord addict
any final words before the camera comes
or did anything to say to the people no
I don't all right I want to wait for my
mic you know my my 250 dollar mic and
I'm using this phone the floor is yours
the floor is yours
[Music]
[Applause]
so he can get the t-shirts made I'm
gonna focus the camera on you you are
here waited you fought valiantly I still
would make the same bet because well at
the end of the day there's no there's no
excuses that could be used he can call
that we pray to his Messiah I think that
you know when it was announced we didn't
really go into specifics the numbers we
were referring to his world numbers but
we didn't go into specifics of what it
was that was meaning world numbers but I
guess MPD somehow got brought into but
you know I got personally tired of
dealing with this so I'm just gonna sit
down so we can move on with though I
appreciate you bringing your head before
the shopping block but the D was very
heavy thank you sir for being a man okay
I have a question deep everyone but
because I feel like you never won best
we've said this before don't ever bet
with him because if you lose yep
you'll hear the rest of your life
[Music]
[Music]
celebratory thank you thank you
I've waited months for this I've looked
and I look fine far and far and this is
the first month it's felt like MPD's yo
its iconic iconic this is this thing
worldwide nobody know that God will he
walk straight through the mall
kids infants will see spider-man let me
ask you think at 80 poker there was no
point you know you know when it was it
was a little far for me
when was this little fun for you well we
went to e3 and I played it hmm only is
the appeal there you like it's also a
good game so you lies that the combo
that really solidified it for you what
what it was is once you touch it and you
get your chance to swing because you
know some people are one person said
they didn't like the swing emotion all
right whatever that you you guy go away
um but if you played all these
spider-man games and I've played them on
GameCube all the way through feedback
you get is you see you sweep like
spider-man that's not it that's the only
pausing I'm gonna beg you sir to let me
talk the salt II don't know what it
really no don't beg King listen man I
don't care what nobody say I knew that
game was gonna do exactly what it did
and to me it's probably the best game
I've played in a decade no lie I'm
telling you it is that good and like I
said maybe I'm seeing it from my my
vision of the game when I play a game
I'm gonna know if I'm able to be as good
as the character you know like feel like
you're into the character I love the
world that they made this is not like a
photorealistic copy of whatever
spider-man is there they made this
character
up they made Aunt May up facial totally
different the world completely different
they went offered a own script on how
they was bringing this world to life and
I thought they did a great job in
fleshing out all the characters so far
that I got a chance to play and give
them them their own space in this Spidey
verse this this world of spider-man that
they made this is their own he said best
game he probably might say something
like fallout no he's skewed to his his
views it's cool you know I play a lot of
games on various systems and what
appeals to me is this game really
appeals to me and a lot of you have a
lot of questions you can do you can um I
mean some people thought it was tedious
going to find book bags but I had a
great time you know finding the book
bags then you do a different base
capturing and implementing your moves as
you build them up you can go back to
those bases to get those quest tokens so
I thought it had a lot of activities for
you in the package that they gave you
and the stories were good um
the world is ever-evolving if you did a
mission it will later on talk about that
same mission in the game a little bit
with James jonah Jameson um so I thought
I thought it was very well thought out
and I just found it to be a fantastic
game and I'm just happy that it did win
MPD's I knew it would mom do I like it
better than God well yes that's my
personal choice some people like god of
war better than anything and that's
great for them and some people like
fallout instead so you know that's great
for them but this for me this game is I
mean come on man obviously I'm a
spider-man fan so you know that was my
thing no doubt let me jump it I mean
this is like to be honest I'll be I was
actually surprised because I knew to be
I wasn't surprised for another reason
and we were done off the month that it
came out it was fierce competition
because not only did it have to deal
with you know I'm saying like a
multi-platinum like NBA
okay every year is a beast like I can't
remember the last time NBA 2k probably
lost one when he dropped and for it to
come out in that month and and as a
multi plan
I remember smile only on you know me so
for it to eat that to me was absolutely
amazing didn't see that comment we had
and then okay we can't understate
Odyssey solve I honestly was amazing was
a real solid entry a lot of people were
raving and I finished number three 2k
finish now mom to fight who was in that
month as well and shadow of the Tomb
Raider like King say so you know what I
didn't at what I didn't expect was out
of the 25 year history history that is
the number one selling exclusive game to
Sony platform any system that they
released crazy crazy this is just
tremendous numbers man and that that's
what made to me be the actual it made it
the victory even more I kind of because
you know when you're talking about
combining every spider-man game ever
made and it still started 37 percent
more than that but that's just insane
and l father you said you predicted it
to a Lord Ram is that you guys had a
conversation he said yeah well to a
bunch of people
look I mean spider-man is got that
universal appeal they've got
spider-man's in other countries like
their versions of spider-man's like the
spider-man is is gonna appeal to a wide
range of people and and he is right when
he says you know even little babies who
look up and see spider-man know a
spider-man I guess just not to cut you
fun but I guess where I was wicked
addicts camp but I gotta get out of his
dad because God of War was so you know
critically acclaimed it was just so it
was such the mind share and and Kenny's
right yes you know my mammy Kratos
walked in the mall a guy dressed up as
cradle to the guy just super spider bed
he's right yeah people gonna know
spider-man but I guess because of the
history of bad spider-man games in the
past and because I thought maybe you
know God want what you so iconic out
here and the reviews the Metacritic and
all that stuff and it just goes to show
you mass appeal you know I gotta
interject though because I got a free
looking at what we saw coming from this
spider-man now you knew right away it
wasn't like those other spider-man's
backsies it looked on another level
though I mean look I haven't played it
yet myself but I'm is my favorite yeah
it looks great
I've heard the story is wonderful yeah I
can't wait to get into the game it was
insane anything else before we move to
you know these people are watching you
right now crumble before they very eyes
Buddhists do so attic
I mean is you on the bed that's all my
two cents real quick before you move on
yeah as soon as this we realize this is
a first party game and this is a this is
going to be like by insomniac and not
some third party sort of like movie
tie-in from Activision the the
excitement level around the game just
shot up and you knew it was gonna be
something specials gonna be something
different and it shows and again
spider-man with that appeal if you give
that type of product to spider-man fans
they're gonna eat it up all over so not
surprising to me
anchorman that I've been seeing
saw what Red Dead is upon us
finally Oh Lord Fonzarelli it's here and
it's always so happy I picked you I
needed some help today I sort of the
wording of what was going on like I'm
gonna come on here and then he's gonna
have play destiny and not played it you
know say I'm like I'm gonna be the only
one talk about red but listen I don't
want this to be just me and fauns
gushing about the game I want a
conversation around this so I know King
hasn't played it I know I know you have
a couple of hours in cog and I know
addict has a couple of hours so I don't
want this to be you what up about 10
hours okay so honestly for a Red Dead
fan I think they did everything that I
expected them to do and more I think
every time a rockstar game comes out
because you see so little of it and I
and I choose to see so little of it when
it finally I have it on the screen I'm
like what the hell did they do and I
think every time I turn this game on I'm
in awe of it I'm like now this is not a
game they didn't do this like the level
of detail in the world the story the
depth of the story
the depth of the characters um it's it's
different than what you expect from a
GTA game like GTA games are very much
satires and the characters are very much
sort of dark reflections of some social
commentary or something like that in
rare dead the characters have depth
especially this particular game these
are layered characters that aren't
necessarily what you expect them to be
even more so in the first red day where
you still had characters that were like
caricatures right there were
representations of ideas or ideas or
whatever this is totally different mom
for me it is a high watermark in game
design in open-world in story and again
I'm touched at much story but just the
layers of it and how the entire world
affects the story um it's sort of
amazing to me the game sort of it's kind
of ridiculous what this game is doing
it's not perfect
I know attic has issues with control and
that and that is a valid valid point
um but I think that's something oh
you click on the home screen the whole
switch is going to explode yes it's
issues with control and I think that's
you know all these games in all these
rockstar games they sort of do that
purposely right it's a it's a it's a
design thing for them it's not like they
got it wrong it's like this is what they
feel the game should feel like um for
better for worse but that said I think
you know everybody's on notice again
they everybody's on notice like this is
the new benchmark try to get us try to
reach us if you can no doubt now let's
get our guest of the hour here
Lord bomb same exact thing said again so
he goes say almost identical with
sovereign Oh
I want to preface it before I give it to
you I mean I want to give you credit
because on obviously you know even in
the heat of the God Wars to spider-mans
you know I've watched the traveler love
us and you have been steadfast on this
game so this is kind of like your moment
you know that's what I thought about you
know I just I want you to talk about
your experience with the game how you
feeling is it everything you expected it
to be more ha what will tell us all
about it man what's going on so I'm
about I'm close to 40 hours in the game
what Wow 40 hours in the game I
definitely it's exceeded my expectations
it's not without its faults the control
system yes it is very Rockstar like if
you hate it you're not gonna like the
controls here it's it's it's just the
way they do it they force you to use
auto-aim
it's not something i i i love per se but
it's something that I've grown
accustomed to with Rockstar Games and
I'm fine with it
do I hope that that in the future they
they change something there improve on
it yes I do that said is that's the only
negative I have on this game that said
this game is pushing the this genre
forward I told people this you know four
months a its Rockstar its Rockstar they
are gonna innovate this is the first
game of this generation that they're
actually putting out there they've been
working on this game for seven plus
years I mean it's been eight years since
Red Dead I have been waiting this for
this title when they finally announced
it in 2016 I like every day I'm like
damn it's a day closer to Red Dead exits
damn father you game testing for
Rockstar
here's the thing I'm a gamer guys you
know I'm gonna play my games and if I
love a game I'm gonna put in the work
okay I I'm only 34 almost 30% into the
story okay I hit that thirty percent
twenty nine percent mark and I said whoa
cut hold on hold on I'm not gonna finish
this just yet so I backed off I spent
the whole day yesterday and I'm talking
many hours yesterday just doing my own
thing living in this world getting
immersed within this world because
that's what this world does it is so
atmospheric the first game was
atmospheric but this game is on another
level I have felt yeah I have not felt a
game being this you know having this
much you know feeling and immersion and
everything in I've never felt this never
I I feel like I'm playing through as
this Arthur Morgan character and by the
way I've grown to love this character
he's amazing
you know that things you go through no
spoilers the things you go through with
this guy as you progress through the
story it's it's really amazing like I
feel like I'm playing as him within the
game and I feel like this immersion is
real and this world is fantastic the
detail within this world is is
precedented the best there was a point
where I was fishing okay and I'm just
fishing and in minding my own business
catching fish Jay Fisher Ellie my horse
is standing there next to me other
Stanwell horse runs away and like what
was that
and I look in the water and there's a
snake snake Wow it's it's interactions
like that I'm hunting and I put this
video up on Twitter by the way you can
check it out I'm hunting out there I
just I just killed the a turkey and I'm
walking back to my horse
I dropped the turkey I bent down to pick
it up and this deer comes out of nowhere
and bucks me right yes I saw that video
you
and I'm like what this game that the the
the stuff that goes on and your rights
off when you say that it's not so
comedic and everything like GTA usually
is but there are those moments because
the town's folk they say some funny
stuff I mean if you just listen to the
town's folk they're hilarious but I that
that's the story itself it's a serious
tone but this view starts off think
hateful eight tarantino an amazing
opening man I just love that not to cut
you cheese
I just love you know the opening and
falls pause but just like you wrote him
riding when should be cruel you're gonna
mean in you know you going off on this
this world and I just wanted I want to
spoil you guys for one point on I think
we're not even really getting into this
graphical detail that's legality right
because are you are we all playing on
the X here I'm assuming of all of us a
plan on the X I'm playing it on the X
and yes the answer anchor yeah I'm
playing just on the X and and I think
like I said I mean I've touched a little
bit of horizon zero dawn you know I've
seen this no and it's very impressive
this looked wow this looked insane to me
you know just that the character models
and stuff like that facial expressions
the seamless transitions between
cinematic and going you know out in the
open world and it's just it's really
mind-blowing in 4k HDR like I must say
just every single little detail and
emerging that drop distance right that's
Rhonda Cole because I think we at peak
capacity you know you know stop the blow
they these PlayStation fans this cold
for this did one of the games of this
generation spider-man no let's get that
out there for these guys guys if you
listen and tuned into the
the show um I believe was gonna give a
question about Red Dead and the cold
would be for the PlayStation so he's
going to give a question and answer it
and it's gonna go out yeah you know what
I'll say it on the air and they can post
it in chat in the way the question is
pretty easy if you played Red Dead
Redemption you you know this the main
protagonist John Marston who is he
played by real-life actor playing it who
is the actor five questions in come on
your chat if you don't want that yeah I
PlayStation fans yeah I want to get a
part of this great hit me up on Twitter
no doubt but yeah so know this came the
immersion in this game is right there
should win based I was saying the draw
distances you see all the foliage the
trees everything out in the distance
like I don't think occupy them so you
must think is really a buggy are you
when you're the ps4 Miss X oh we throw
that back in the bushes let the other
chat and let no second place with her
with that let us know al book yeah see
you to chat yeah the fact that I don't
see a lot of popping going on in this
world is amazing to me there's a little
bit here in there very rare and it just
shows you that you know all these hours
that and dedication that this team has
put in Rockstar is on another level
I'm sorry when it comes to open world
games nobody does it like them nobody
out there better
question them because they are amazing
or what they do I mean they flat-out are
amazing this game is gonna sell a lot
will it sell GTA numbers no not nothing
ever sells like GTA that modernized you
know civilization is so much different
this is the 1899 you know so a lot of
people just can't get into the cowboy
setting and I get yeah yeah but but I
think that you know like I said urging
the the when you do get into the combat
and you do start fighting and you get
new guns and upgrade your guns and stuff
I'm having fun with that I'm like
blowing heads off literally I've got
videos up showing that on my channel by
the way it's just one this game you know
you're fun let me ask you a question
like because when I found out it was
running native 4k on Xbox X um that blew
me away that Rockstar was able to code
that well got down to the metal that
well of the game of that magnitude that
graphical fidelity that they're
demanding on the processes and and the
CPU was able to get it into a native 4k
which sent Twitter into mayhem alright
um what did you think you heard that it
was made of 4k before cuz I'm pretty
sure that you heard about it before you
purchase the game and I know your
excitement level probably just shot no
no I'm not big when it comes to just
resolution bumps so I like everything
that goes along with graphic fidelity
you know you know the ambient occlusion
all that stuff you know all the
technical stuff that they throw out
there at you but this game I was
expecting okay now that they're saying
this is full 4k and is it going to be
dumbed down I was I was kind of worried
honestly was and I was thinking well his
performance really gonna take a hit
that's what my question what I was
questioning well when I started playing
this game but the visuals automatically
that was that that was gone it might be
my feeling on that being negative was
gone
but the performance I will paint gonna
lie there are some moments where it does
dip a little bit here and there it's not
just in a cutscene
like digital foundry said it's in other
areas I feel it but it's not anything
terrible at all it doesn't dip the way
down into like the low 20s or anything I
mean we're talking about a few frames
here however but it's it's it's when
things really get heated up and stuff
battles and stuff no I mean the game is
it's incredible the story is amazing so
far and if it continues down this path I
will say this got a war
you're already slid over for my game of
the year notice already no that's
already in the bushes
I'm only 29% into the to this game so
therefore this is gonna be my game of
this whole generation I'm telling you
now
the only way they can mess this up is if
at the end it just completely just the
truth of all like the story yeah that's
the only way man to be perfectly honest
everything that faun says I echo
everything like thing about this game
now we go get it we lady at lady Lucas
in the chair and I got some things to
say I'm expecting good things from it
what I know what I know it's about the
naysayers I'm gonna generalize it's
younger people who don't who don't like
you know smelling the roses and stopping
it's not like an addict child none of
those things like you're not willing to
inhabit the world and like and take the
world for what it is and you just want
to run through the game and you just you
if you're if your entertainment level
has to be at a thousand all the time and
constantly in the middle of a fight or
something like that this is not the game
for you it just you know the native um
you missed an easy
right now this is probably gonna be one
of the most watched episode I highly
encourage you to after it goes up to RO
lactate get that part where the Me's
actually was up on that ground because
salt was added to the knees and the
blood was gushing all over the place and
tears were shed so I think you honestly
want to see that from the beginning
native I'm so happy that you did show up
my friend I see everybody in the chat I
just had to say that because I know he
wanted to look forward to that part and
he probably woke up like the knees don't
the means don't we would solve in the
fact that this game is more simulation
than it is arcade yes you definitely
like have to take your time in this game
and in a lot of areas and what I mean by
that is that rockstars added new
mechanics to the game where it wasn't
there before like you actually have to
eat you have to feed your horse you have
to take care of your horse you have to
take care and then our very good about
telling you how to implement these
mechanics they're not really good at
onboarding you for this sort of stuff
it doesn't hit yeah it doesn't work but
at the same time it's the mechanics
aren't hard to wait you can starve to
death you can starve no you can starve
to the point where your health core goes
all the way down and what you won't die
necessarily it'll just be slowly way
down and you could see it physically on
Arthur's face and he's slouched over and
his face looks real tired he looks
messed up yeah you have to eat but you
can you can watch it and and the thing
is is I hear a lot of people saying it's
tedious they don't like doing it I'm
only doing it like once an hour and I'm
good
like that right you shout out boys solid
red I don't know what people are really
upset about because it really isn't that
intrusive at all it's just it's there
it's a new mechanic and I actually like
that there's more to do within the
while you're you know going around doing
stuff the fact that you like I spent
there was this one time I got bit by a
poisonous snake well told me that I had
to I had to eat some ginseng to get rid
of this poison or whatever so I'm out
looking for wild ginseng and I'm okay
with that
like you know one going around picking
up all these flowers and stuff because
they do add to your health like there's
some some flowers that will give you
health if you eat it so I do that takes
care of that just there so there's so
much more going on in this game than the
first one that I enjoyed I appreciate it
I like what they did here it's really
layered and if you're not willing to do
that you're not and you're not gonna get
the most out of this world like okay um
Greg Miller said this does not game for
him and knowing how Greg Miller is yeah
it's not the game for him he's not he
needs to be entertained every minute of
every second or he's not he's not gonna
be willing to sort of immerse himself in
that and that minutia and if you're that
type of gamer you're gonna you're gonna
be frustrated by this don't get it
twisted though when there is action
moments when you're in the firefight
it's fast it's just it's frantic crabs
[Laughter]
so I gotta get in here because obviously
there's another side to this the game
was out now at a comedy how much would
you say you have about in ready a
Redemption - all right so based on
everything that you've played what's
how's your experience been you know I
know when we talked offline you had some
serious issues with the control so let
me give me your overall experience with
these people that are giving it a ten
out of ten
they're on something on one part of it I
I just like you know and I get what
people are saying about the controls
their clunky and I get tired no offense
Lord Falls people say it's a rock star
that is not an excuse to keep doing it
over and over again like when I was in a
I was in a shoe now I have to interject
when you say it's a rockstar you well
here's the thing it's a design
implementation this is the way they
designed the game this boy did he design
all their games whether you like it or
not that's up to you but not a mistake
it's not a mistake instead our purpose
doesn't mean it's the right choice that
they make I think what they're going for
with this game they look they're going
for a cinematic feel they're going for a
filmic feel so they don't it's not as
important to them that the shooting
feels as good as it doesn't Cod what's
important to them is that 80% of what
you doing so why I know what they want
you to do
quantity how you tell me the gameplay it
wants you to use Deadeye that's what
they want you to do that the shooting
isn't supposed to be one of the most
important things of the game so attic
talked about the shooting I just don't
agree with that man like I don't like
what last night I was having some
serious issues with those controllers
trying to shoot manat to Michie you you
yourself feel like you're 500 pounds
trying to move around like I have to
jump into attic I do agree with you over
one point - I do feel I feel his
problems a week the controls are
definitely a controversial thing right
if you've played rockstar games before
new this is this comes with their
territory right but if you compare what
they're doing now in 2018 compared to
what everyone else has been doing you
know I'm saying as far as just running
mapping buttons to the Run button
crouching getting behind cover in a fast
kind of fluid motion it's definitely
like slower than a little bit clunky and
I will give attic this even when I was
when you like sometimes when you just
like let's say you know a big firefight
has gone down and now it's time to loot
the bodies and stuff like that and
you're going through every
kind of meticulous it is a little slow I
felt that's to my person going to get
guy I'm gonna let you figure out it just
just just little certain little tasks
again minor nitpick stuff but I do see
what he said as far as he cut almost a
little bit of molasses feel but continue
at it you know I just want to say a
couple things the game is amazing it is
like you know the immersion if anything
one thing I'm getting annoyed with is
people saying that they innervated is I
I saw someone sound be going up a hill
and your your horse is sad and was going
up acting like a stand of a bar ain't
been a part of like they'll be like you
know I guess this seems a good game it
is it's a great game the emergence there
the game is gorgeous that they
definitely put like if you make I
wouldn't go anything if you make an
open-world game it needs to feel mersive
like this right the games that have been
really successful this year they have
had a huge huge focus on emergent yes
you know that's what makes this game
good but as far as people trying to
excuse the gameplay saying you know
that's a rockstar game saying that's
that that's their tip how is it everyone
else around them is improving their
gameplay mechanics when terms of
shooting but Rockstar no one's saying
I've got a question for you to chat
McEvoy attend says what's wrong with the
shooting attic well he wasn't know what
specifically you don't like them it's
just it just feels too clunky man like I
don't understand how I can explain it
when I go to shoot like if those like
like old-school Resident Evil that type
of clunky or does it feel like room when
they revamp the controls for Resident
Evil but does it feel like that type of
revamp go is bad to say like the old
resident evils but it's too much better
okay yeah it's like GTA like you know
how GTA felt heavy yeah what when
someone even lose a slight I can't move
my person to the degree they move their
person mmm I think you're trying to
adjust my sha and it doesn't work the
way they're moving it feels like month
if those like I have a cannon in my hand
and not a pistol mmm
yeah I mean again this this may not be
enough but there are some things in the
in the options to change with the
control change so no Tories you're
notorious for not using the tools at
your disposal when you play a game so
it's like I shouldn't be Rolla I
shouldn't I'm tired of people they're
not something doesn't feel quite right
to you in a game why is it why does it
have to be the games busted and you just
can't do things that's why why can't i
but there's certain things I'm trying to
give you I'm trying to give you a way
for it to feel better and you're like no
sir forces people on Twitter said that
they'd done these and it's still isn't
it laughs you haven't done I don't you
ever done you got it do it do it
you haven't done it act like it fixes it
when there's countless but you're
shooting me down before you even hear me
I have to I have to I have to agree with
addict that you know he's not wrong in
his assessment that you know the
controls could be better I agree but
then why people can't say yeah the
game's amazing but the controls I want I
want I want it I want to defend addict
because I do feel where he's coming from
the only thing I do feel is there
sometimes you know when a game comes out
regardless if the game is a masterpiece
and it is fantastic sometimes we do as I
say we but sometimes journalism I don't
want to say everyone gets caught up in
hyperbole but sometimes when a game is
so good that we overlook little four
little minor things right that other
games may not be you know that will be
subject to right so in his defense I
didn't hear anything about the controls
when I saw you know interview shot no
dick no shade
you know they turn up you know I saw a
lot of other media outlets put the ten
like that and this is where me an addict
are similar when you throw ten on
something right even when Zelda was
getting tense
you know saying like I'm gonna come in
with the extra critical eyes like now
I'm coming in right but basically when
you throw ten or something you're saying
gaming perfection right now saying you
guys here in the panel I'm talking
around table I'm just talking bout like
the media the journalism stuff like that
so again that's gonna make me come in
extra heart and that's when instead of
me just trying to enjoy the game of the
birds but stuff that I start looking for
so I do sovereign would you toss me that
the code in the chat again when I rep on
the phone and came back I don't have
okay I was gonna say well I I do want to
say that when I first started talking
about this I did mention that the
controls weren't that you know you guys
are pointing it out yeah I do hear what
he's saying because I go first let one
of my mate beyond I was I was kind of in
the lord king school of thought when
read there got announced I said I'm
going to get it but because of my back
law because that's nice oh good yeah I
was just like I really shouldn't do it I
don't have time but then when I see the
tens flowing right okay this is that's
the thing that I'm talking about you got
game that you were playing that you put
down and he was like man I got let me
jump into this game now me personally
and this is just a meeting um I know I
still got games rap from last Black
Friday last year's Black Friday in in
the rapper you understand and I said I
gotta stop becoming a collector and him
become I want to do that Fonzarelli sit
down forty hours and let's go week off a
game tation just to catch up on backlog
that's what it turned into
that's what we turned into like that's
why I sat down I said I gotta finish the
spider-man because I thought I'll be
finished with that spider-man before the
dlc came out
and my mom was like you're the dlcs out
I was like what was like you were doing
it up and I said you know what and I
didn't like how to implement to the dlc
in there and there's something totally
depressing oh but I say I'm going to
buckle down on this game I'm going to
finish this game and then i'ma finish
the DLC and then I'm gonna get to read
day and I figured by the time that comes
around I couldn't wait probably a couple
of days to Black Friday to get the the
target by to get one free type of thing
cuz I want a Tomb Raider i want the
Odyssey so I said those are three games
I can get I can give you one game free
out of there and and that was my whole
thought going into that you guys someone
give something at ten out of ten first
thing that you think of like like I feel
like a ticket is them saying yo Red Dead
does everything that read that brought
to the table at the highest quality it
could possibly do for K native on a game
of death statute that that alone was
supposed to make me hit the download
button let me let me you know liken it
to another huge game that people love
and it's near and dear to people's
hearts but for me I don't like the
combat controls at all and that's
Witcher 3 okay I think would be
storytelling is amazing the game itself
is is amazing looking visually it's it's
it is on that masterpiece level but the
combat for me I didn't like right though
I mean different strokes for different
people I mean that here's the thing when
I see tens that people give these games
tens I don't like it because it isn't
perfect because when they do talk about
the game when they break it down in this
in the same video they give it a ten in
and they also give you some negatives so
why would you give a game a ten if there
is some negatives right so you always
have to shave a few points off it for
that
you know you have to so I've never given
a game of ten and I won't because
nothing is powerful I'm of the same my
positive way we go at it right but this
game is brilliant it's really on so many
levels so far really it's not perfect
but it's brilliant out of ten you just
getting a nitpicky right you can't
figure anything out because you enjoyed
so much quality that you have to start
nipping now the game does seem like you
know thawne's enjoyed it so is probably
you know around that level for him but I
feel like you know the controls is a
huge part of the game right no one oh I
gotta tell you one thing mom and I meant
to tell you when you jumped in the chat
I played that Center cuz you said I
wasn't gonna do it I downloaded it up
late it brother it is ten times harder
than that stuff that we played when we
were there take my hat off to you my
friend
appreciate hard thanks y'all appreciate
the love to the podcast as a tip much
love to the Lords of the ladies in the
brown this games a great game the
emergence there the stories there when
you're going on your courts with the
characters you know you can have
conversations with them the voice acting
I don't think I've seen a better voice
acting game everything on this game is
great a material but the shooting
mechanics when the controls but when I
bring that up people want to act like
that doesn't exist that's not an excuse
not excuse an excuse but it's obviously
a design choice yes so in that respect
it's like okay am I gonna keep being
pissed off at this in this game or am I
gonna figure out if I love the game that
much am I gonna figure out yeah no I
agree with saw Vaughn that he's on a
percent right I mean this is their
choice like you could say what you want
like honestly adding I agree with you in
that you don't like the controls but at
the end of the day the
is the design choice for them like the
game the game controlled is tight is
like a car or something like that the
game wouldn't feel as that world
wouldn't feel as as immersive to me
because if now it feels gamy and the
game is a little gamey the game is meant
to feel cinematic the game is meant to
feel real and grounded like you in real
life if you pull out a gun you're
probably not gonna be able to aim
perfectly as quickly I'm with you sorry
I got I got a cut you just wasn't
relevant either made a fantastic point
which is what I was gonna say and this
is again leaving back the Attic and I
gotta give at it it says so then why
can't it have bloody map button mapping
is so 2018 why does this do I can't I
choose specifically what I want in this
day and age you guys have to understand
it because gaming has evolved to a point
right give them a pass for archaic
things that haven't been updated despite
everything else being fantastic despite
the most greatest cinematic going back
that's back to Rockstar see Rockstar
want to play their vision make no
mistake right they want you to be
immersed in this world but they want you
to be immersed in the world they create
it right so can they create updated
controls no I'm not saying saying
fallout 3 they want to use the bat
system just because they want to use the
baptism does not mean that but there's a
[ __ ] I put aim down sights in a
first-person shooter game but but let me
tell you something
the aim-down-sights in that game was
trash to me anyway science in 4 & 3 Oh
time I for I'm talking about three one
but that is the large fallout 3 people
give them all the praise no one really
said anything about them not having any
doubt sights in a first-person shooter
if there was people would like sovereign
saying that's what the been told you
still have implement that in there
because it is a first-person shooter
giving your giving your customers the
ability to do what they want to to remap
the controller isn't not nothing
they want to play I took Knights out of
this that's not rock star
the frogs dog that's not rock star give
you a sandbox to play in
according to their rule box what is
there you know what the bottom line is
this you like it or you don't right
that's true I don't like the game I'm
saying you can at least admit that you
know they are issue controls the media
and social media but everyone on this
panel agrees with what you're saying so
we got to be clear about that is not
living in this fantasy world agree with
it today Rockstar don't bend the knee
that's true they don't bend the back you
talk about the the acting in the game
it's impeccable man honestly the acting
and the charismatic Dutch yes sir
oh my let me jump in let me jump because
ya got you doing off on a tangent
listen I've only got about what seven
eight hours um I've taken more time you
know at the end of the day I will say
this this is like a real-life western
cowboy simulator like this thing is
complete immersion this thing is
cinematics on the highest level there's
some times where I just stopped to see
what I'm doing hit that camera option
cinematic option rotate and just be an
amazement at the detail just be an
amazement of this world that I'm in and
there's so many little nuances just
things like hitching your horse and you
know like hogtied someone on the back
little things it's all so violent it's
visual the carrot
yelling calling you I got five okay
[Music]
eight was in the menus thing is it is
truly really like it's like next-level
in terms of cinematic storytelling and
again seamless transition between action
like people were doing that more and
more often and one thing about the thing
is like I just felt like each member of
the squad I was able to do something
with you like the character building
fawns like the relationships going out
on the hunt oh it gets it gets more on
emotional level it's it's it really does
there's there's some missions that I'm
doing that I'm like damn dude and the
big thing they touted with the world
reacting to you in a very real way you
hear stuff like that you know you think
back to Peter Molyneux and fable and all
the promises this game really delivers
on that like when you do something
mm-hmm there there are repercussions
that ripple throughout the entire world
literally two places you haven't been to
yet if you did something big enough some
ways performance somebody that heard
that is gonna somehow you you'll be
known someplace else and that's gonna
let me give you an example so there's
this there's this town in the game one
of the first towns you go the one you
get in that first bar fight see I've
gotten into so many bar fights a bar
even though I've paid the bounty hate
you you walk in there like you know it's
worse than that like I hear the piano
and everything I walk in there the piano
stops they all look at me and then they
all start talking [ __ ] and and I'm like
what like I'm just here to get a haircut
and then you have to come you have to
bring people down like if somebody comes
to you and they're like listen man I'm
not here for this and you're like no I'm
good don't worry about it today we good
there's no
today I listen I went into I went into
the UM sheriff's office to pick up a
bounty when I go into the sheriff's
office he's talking to a woman on the
side and they're talking about something
private they didn't want anybody to hear
but they didn't
I sort of burst in so he stops the
conversation quickly and they moved to
the back and it just seems Shady
so later on I come back there and to
deliver the bounty and I decided to go
around back
yeah and I go around back and I climb to
the top of this like this like a back
staircase you can go and it's like an
upper room I hear him arguing with this
woman I've said that woman is his
mistress and she's arguing with him
because he doesn't want to leave his
wife and I guess he's been mistreating
her whatever and she's fed up with it
that all of this just continues on so
obviously there's some story thread
beyond that that you're gonna have to
deal with at some point that's crazy
that's just nuts
oh one thing I want to say too is that
this every little side mission that I've
been doing everything feels so cohesive
like one big melting story that I can
swing through one big thing it doesn't
feel disjointed at all and that is one
thing I really love about this game is
it's like and and all these missions
it's promised like it means something
like Mirage everything's over rock into
something not nice yeah definitely like
a lot of cohesion I want ask one like us
before we're gonna kill to solve it um
the last thing is obviously the ex and
the effect of the ex and we've seen the
review shout out the Lord John Lennon
made a digital found you've had him on
the show great guy and he was the first
to kind of break down the technical
aspects of the game so obviously when
the results came in and you know the ex
was not only the superior version but I
think too many surprised and me and so
I've had this discussion and a Takei
discussion offline that it was native 4k
you know I'm saying so when that news
but I wanna bring still around to be
like how did everyone feel about kind of
like the ex being such a superior
version I shout to Brian altano he had a
tweet and he's he's a Sony guy doing
through like altano he plays everything
but he's a somebody guy coming through
and he just said he had
and he was like look man you know I've
been playing about 12 hours of this on
ps4 Pro and he just happened to see it
or get ahold of it on the X and he's
like because the difference is so
substantial I'm going to end my
playstation and start a new state over
on the X because it just was night and
day to him so like what do we think what
allure think about that you know as far
as the X's you know the power jump
between it let me you guys know I'm not
the biggest on you know that whole 4k
talk thing Rex but the one thing I it's
like you know what the whole red dead
thing it's like why can't we just a bit
that the Xbox X has the the better
version like it
why would can we is that like I feel
like people's pride outweighs facts for
some reason lorries out there fighting
the good fight nothing wrong with saying
okay the X is a superior version if you
have an X and a probe and you want a
better version you should probably buy
that Pro Plan performing worse than the
regular well some people are having HDR
issues on the pro as well as some
flurries but I also want to put in an
attic on it because I also want to put
in another caveat the reason why I also
think this is bigger than normally
resolution gates right is that Red Dead
Redemption is notoriously not a PC a
right so for the first time in right for
the first time in multi plaque I don't
say history but you know in a long time
rifles like the X is the only place you
can play the better version normally the
PC crowd would say okay that's cool I'll
play it on PC but there's no plans for
Rockstar T and now C's right so they
have they ever brought they first Red
Dead Redemption and here's the thing
about this whole situation first of all
I got to say how's that marketing deal
Sony
I can't I gotta say look when it comes
down to it like we said earlier this is
rock star they don't I don't bend the
knee to nobody so when they have a
marketing deal with somebody yeah
they'll throw you a sombrero and a horse
and whatever right at the end end of the
day they want to put their product out
and make it look the best possible akin
on every platform right right they're
gonna do that there because they want to
market this game to everybody they want
to sell this game to everyone so why
would they not make it look great right
as possible as they could on every
platform so the X that's why I think it
looks as good as it does because I think
these other companies you know I won't
say lazy I won't say yeah but those are
not as dedicated as Rockstar is right
also that Rockstar has that mentality
where they're like well I'm glad you
brought that up King because again the
expanse is on it because one of the
questions coming in when the X was
announced and we knew for the most part
multi plattsburgh
but the question always remain like
right like a game was dead like a game
like destiny where Sony has to market
like a game like rock read everything to
Sony has to marketing right would that
influence the dev right there but these
are the rumors with the XK about like
would that influence the deaths had not
make the better version on the opposing
platform right I can just say this for
that hmm remember when we said it took
fortnight to make Sony bend the knee
mm-hmm I believe rockstar is such a big
company that they like like like fine
said yeah okay you know we got the
market right here's our sombrero here's
a little holster um but at no point in
time will we dumb down our product to to
make you happy you know um you will have
this exclusive content that we're gonna
shovel your way but we're gonna put this
to the highest extent we can get it out
there and whatever platform can run it
on what what our vision is then that's
gonna be the lead platform and
who you wrecked I think I think Red Dead
Redemption to the significance of it
it's solidified that what you just say
like it did yeah and this is it you know
me I keep it honest I I'm not I'm middle
of the road when it comes to these
consoles right but I have a couple of
friends that bought the ex just for this
game yes I'm seeing that and again I'm
seeing also because of the lack of PC
port even more so right because it's the
only place you can get it they waited
for that digital foundry to see if it
was really essential difference to that
hundred dollars off if you bought red
dead yes shop l-boogie said anyone run
me a horse full-speed into a tree gets I
have I was escaping I was escaping after
I raided like this little farmhouse and
that I got wanted so I was trying to
like finish like just kind of scouring
the place and then the cops got there
and bounty hunters got there and I tried
to run out and I went full speed into a
tree and they into another horse it's
like guys we got on Red Dead if the Lord
are good this was interesting we had
about this news again so obviously you
know we've heard obviously the delays
and things of that nature but according
to cloakroom you know and he's had some
rumors in the ass he actually was one of
the first to leak the Microsoft
acquisition playground games and the
Obsidian acquisition so um he started
leaking some stuff on Twitter in
reference to crackdown 3 so he said that
of the city and crackdown 3 is huge not
only is it only twice inside the
original crackdown on top of that
features $1,000 for you to fine and he
said verticality is very key in
crackdown and he talked about how hot
the towers are so on and so forth then
here was
the big one in my opinion he said
development crackdown 3 is essentially
the story of building to complete unique
experiences sumo digital they're
handling the campaign both the
single-player offline and online co-op
for four players which I'm interested in
and here's the big one
he said ruffian games Rafi they're doing
the wrecking zone multi players that
still features 100% cloud destruction
and he put in craw parentheses yes they
did it so I want to bring this to the
laws we know crackdown has been in the
news multiple times probably for the
wrong reasons but with this information
[Laughter]
he's talking about off he's got is my
yeah we got Mew daddy view that but on
yeah with this information now coming
out you know Lord funds like what do you
feel about this hot does this change
anything for you look I need you talking
point I'm tired of hearing about
crackdown I just want to see no I want
to either see the multiplayer
destruction or I don't want to hear
about this game ever again crackdown one
for me was a good game it was all
cracked down to not so much right but
looking at the crackdown three footage
that we saw it I mean it looks like
crackdown right there
I mean will it hold up in today's gaming
yeah I don't know
but the multiplayer destruction that's
interesting you know that's really
interesting what we got to see it now so
if let me double down which you could
follow me down what if it is proven to
be true what if crowbill is saying you
know this thing is true and it does have
these fit these physics that for the
most part people reclining because they
like you know they don't think it's
gonna exist and you know let's say it is
implemented in a good way like does that
change or did the multiplayer did the
cloud structures really didn't have any
well in that in that regard it would
change the fact that we haven't seen any
other game do destruction like quite
like this and that regard I would be
happy because it pushes in
ovation you know I like that so I'm
definitely interested in seeing it but
again
seeing is believing in vitamin fact now
it's like it's all day reaction did
that's why I didn't understand why no
it's not the same thing like if you were
to watch that destruction when they were
shooting that the wall with the gun each
hole was going in you know exact spot
where it was breaking the wall down and
stuff like in in those red factions and
those other games like they shoot in a
wall that breaking points
III give that up to the limitation of
the technology at that time and you know
this is an evolution what I believe
evolution to of their technology now a
hundred percent destructibility I never
faulted in my thoughts in that happening
I played the single-player game I said
oh my god this is disgusting it looks
like part one I'm like somebody turned
off the graphics button and I was like
brother if they don't get it together
all the way in the bushes shout out to
bone slave but on it in the bushes boss
move I feel exactly what you're saying I
physically put hands on it was somebody
that was there needle can attest it is
who has actually in the game that was a
talking point you know um because his
likeness was in the game then you say no
I'm good and I was like man that's
that's not a good sign right there and
they heard you know these guys have
pride took it back you know Phil so Phil
SOI it was probably the least played
game there um you know let's take this
back so how can we fix this to get it to
the point that is acceptable
adjustable to the public yeah I don't
care how far you got to move it back you
know boss move four years you've been
hearing it I don't care if it's four
more years
good games take time don't rush hour a
bad product because a bad product is a
bad product whatever you know but delay
is a delay momentarily so just just get
it right and don't don't stick it in
between leg legs like they did with
Laura cross they put her in the middle
of all these snipers and it game didn't
sell properly and they had to draw price
and don't don't do that just take the
time with this game what it needs
halo packing I remember last year before
it was supposed to come out originally
in 2017 at the end of the year I knew
Phil Spencer in a party chat August or
September of that year and I was at you
know they told me before I got in there
I prefaced by saying hey fonts fonts we
know you ask a lot of questions don't
don't
so what if phones do I asked a lot so
when I went in there I picked this brain
about a whole bunch of stuff and then I
said hey so what game are you looking
most forward to coming out on the X this
this this year and he said crackdown 3
he was adamant he said crackdown 3 is
great it's moved along great it's gonna
come out you know and he loves crackdown
and I'm like ok cool you know he's back
in this product yeah and then not even
two weeks later it was delayed that
conversation I was like Phil like you
mean you didn't know but he loves its
products and what did he put his hands
on approach oh it's let's be honest I
feel what you saying it it's funny I was
saying that I gotta give Phil credit on
this one only for this day but he seems
to be very much involved with this
project right because when the first
delay happened didn't we hear sob that
he was like oh yeah I gotta put that in
of it like I reckon I will say that the
way he was talking it up he loves Craig
he loves crackdown Gaza yeah he was he's
he's been to like the the biggest most
vocal critic about where the game is
like he he hasn't ever since that
initial delay where you know
it went back after III he said it like
he I played it it's not quite there yet
it needs more it's not quite there it
needs more so that I mean that's more
forthcoming that I would expect anybody
to be
oh you're wanting it to go the way a
scalebound is not gonna go that way
coming out it's coming out um for me I'm
kind of in the same boat with fawns like
I was I was just hopeful to get a decent
single-player experience that sort of
mirrored the first ones but I gotta get
hit with all this man with this cloud
destruction addicts did it you know it's
Mike beautiful obedient no he's going on
in the back if not we'll get him back
yeah okay cool
crowd the struggle even when I have this
muted now for some reason it doesn't
mute right now yeah real quick conscious
we got some tops to Flacco car
destruction it Smith
Joe we see this in person okay good
authority again oh my god I mean I
people that this is gonna be a good game
I have already King there's a lot of
talk going on about it right now
so they made both statements that they
couldn't they couldn't really do
anything way announced to her I think
that when it came down to it on that
reasons they don't announce stuff as
early as they did how did they learn the
lesson like that because if you look at
it from a standpoint this is aims that
are being out and is being brutally like
low on the matter
critic or you know they being a
commercial headache like scalebound all
those games were announced in 2013 and
14 like these gate like cartel is that
last one of these games because the rest
have been cancelled or they've been kept
there that came out by now yeah I say I
feel let me you got anything else and
I'll jump in in the chat though she said
besting MS can do is for Xbox has put a
real gamer in charge
I disagree I'll boogie you know I after
talking to Phil the guy I mean he's got
a lot of knowledge and games and he
plays a lot of games the guy he knows
his stuff
man I think L is coming fulfilled or she
may be talking I think let me I'm a
beatnik he's coming from really if I'm
wrong I'm wrong but I think there was a
big controversy when they were
advertising crackdown and they had some
non-gamers kana advertising left and a
fantastic video now be able to say this
on the air but I'm gonna say it anyway
what Phil said but I don't care he was
sitting there he was telling us what
developers play games what don't who
don't like he was like going you don't
play games I'm sitting there listening
going watch like why is he saying this
like no we gotta give credit where
credit is due
like Ibarra to Stilwell's the Phills you
know I mean these doors
they shouted a McCullar Xbox like a lot
of these dudes really game and that's
rare cuz normally it's usually like a
corporate suit kind of thing by our
product but these dudes ain't claim you
know so they bout that life so we got it
we got to give it up you know Mike came
down to crack down is if they would have
promised what they promised I thought
they could have won it a different
direction because now it's like if you
don't have that multiplayer work in the
way that they claimed it's gonna be
considered an L regardless yeah so now
they get the try to fit that in as best
as possible I feel like it could have
went towards a good successful co-op
story with like a GTA you know blowed up
multiplayer then I think that would have
been better than the route they're going
now Chuck the Lord of salt in the chat
Louis Ortiz gable of that rubber damn
car by the way so fly so royal anyway
let me finish this up Baggins got
something to say on it um yeah pretty
much agree with everybody in the panel I
listen I hear what you coming from
France
absolutely definitely where you come
from I think for me you know in Lord
King said they said it best like I've
been on record saying how disgusted I
was when I saw it in 2016 or 2017
wherever that was you know a shout out
to my boy Lord cupcake though cuz
obviously he's in the game and he looked
great he said whatever that was with
this news I'm very intrigued they're
like you know the cloud destruction to
be honest the only reason why I'm
purchasing this game well game passing
this game like I want to see that tech I
want to see what it do even if it do
fall on its face I just want to see what
they were attempting to create right so
at the end of the day I also want to
talk about the teaser teaser that they
showed at all this year 1283 2018 I was
talking to keep it look good look better
the more they look way better than what
I was in front of in 2016 you know say
they looked way better so that the
vehicles the four player co-op
definitely is something I'm interested
in and the engine again it looks
substantially better so my thing is you
know I want to see what happens
likely it's I'm thinking it's going to
be revealed at this Excel
yes it's hurt by a lot of people behind
the scenes okay cool
cuz at this point if it's not a tech so
I don't know if these things because you
know Spencer can't change his mind
within two weeks
Oh Mike LuAnn at eBay we gotta come with
this blaze through Oh banjo kazooie
Bruce what's going on in yeah there's a
lot of different things going on
particularly want to make this too long
but this last Excel oh there was rumored
that banjo kazooie's getting a gallon
oaf is gonna be seek or reboot it looks
like they just renewed the licensing it
looks like it's rumored it's going to be
in the Super Smash Brothers I feel like
all of these are true because I've been
told you know that this is always been
something they've been looking at but I
didn't know who's gonna make it cuz I
don't think rare is gonna make something
like this so I just wanted to go you
know go around first on video and then
you even played banjo kazooie played
oval and you go I have not fons yeah
unfortunately I played it in the chat
box is going crazy
Bonzo in the bushes we got the best
shooting the eggs out of the birds
better gameplay even has a market
anymore do you think not unless not
unless they're trying to make a Mario
caliber platformer and I don't think
they're gonna make
a calendar well I would say this I think
the original banjo came after at Mario
64 and it made improvements on that
formula to the fact that I think it's a
better game but it just think the power
of Mario it's like when you think about
platformer you think about Mario you'd
only think about anything else but the
platforming markets just opened it up
since then people I don't know market a
little bit more now has really been
successful is Mario like you see ukulele
didn't do great and I was that was the
only this would sell too are those but
they would have that nostalgic feeling
about playing it when they were a kid
back then it seemed like it did horrible
I know I did it did great you did great
I just think they would have to make a
Mario caliber platformer but here's the
thing to resonate between to get new
players involved I think what what these
kids are gonna do is they're gonna type
into Google banjo kazooie and they're
gonna take one second of that footage
and go no I don't think so
I was gonna sell the game and we have
known that game pass is definitely the
low-vis the wave so if you like it or
not you're gonna have it for free so
it's not a beating what game path
definitely needs is more kid or and our
family-friendly oriented adventure games
in the vein of that Mario so who not you
know but the either the best of the
second best in that genre to bring that
franchise back they have it they have
real user everybody keeps saying yo we
want this and we want that from rare we
sick and tired of them making these
avatars
alright the avatar stuff is done now
this avatar stuff is in the bushes now
let's get to these games let's start
putting these guys to work let's let's
see I don't even think the whole team is
still there anymore I just think they're
whole they have them in name sake the
studio name sake only um maybe a couple
of guys is still there but they have the
property you have the IP use the IP you
know they should remain if they gonna do
it conquers out then let's get these
games going Hey
what they should do is because it's
gonna be you know I don't think this
mark is not impossible to get into but I
didn't think it done right could do
something it would work well on the city
I do what they need to do is they need
to reimagine the very first one honestly
these type of games would work great on
the switch dude I'm telling you but this
is where the steam comes in and you can
play it on your phone any way you want
to be on your tablet so you write it's
on your switch but just switch to your
phone he said he was rare to bring the
Kraken back this is great at the end of
the day this is all coming from that
link right right Lord addict which is on
the smash brothers league where
obviously they saw evidence that you
know back suggest that bad news will be
in that game as a secret character so
this could potentially be beginning of
this groundbreaking kind of relationship
XO and then probably a couple weeks
later the season pass for Super Smash
Brothers is gonna come out and they're
gonna try to cross-promote them right so
pretty much what it is the leaked I dog
Shadow the Hedgehog Isaac from Golden
Sun and then banjo kazooie that was
apparently what snapchat image from we
don't know if it's 100% true but that's
where this is kind of coming from and it
does kind of make sense based on the
relationship if it is true the
relationship between Microsoft and
Nintendo you know me personally this is
not for me I'm wonderful I mean this is
not for me but I do understand that a
lot of people you know saying would be
very interested in title like that you
know it is is it relevant it all comes
down to you know if people on a
Microsoft platform I'm gonna pick that
type of a title up because to switch to
the phone's defense you know these tends
to be kind of switch type of titles but
they do Microsoft does control the IP if
they let my on Nintendo use it you know
are they planning I mean you know borrow
it for whatever like are they planning
to actually do something on their own
the IP you're gonna be present if
they let Nintendo make it and let it
come out for Xbox and Nintendo mmm
thing is gonna be just remasters on game
pass
gajju but they they already have that on
rewrite replay why would they redo it
wasn't remastered at all over every
wasn't remastered don't like so it was I
mean ever since backwards compatibility
what have they really done that way they
haven't really touching anything like
that well maybe they'll remaster and put
it out on the switch to demographic is
there on the switch I'll come by the
last two which is to news obviously
first on shout out such a Nutella he had
on a conference call game pass so the
first is on Xbox game pass and expanding
the market he said in this latest
earnings call that he said pretty much
Xbox has the key gaming community and
the monetization capabilities so he's
definitely thinking about expanding to
game past launch to PC so I was the
first thing and then the second thing
which was various actually hot off the
presses
our main just Gordon and I'm saying from
Windows central also part of the Xbox to
you know he had put this out in
reference to UM the X cloud and we all
know you know the Microsoft Project s
cloud has come out and you know we saw
that the the pictures in reference to
immediately the demos of - these guys
playing and streaming things on the
cloud so um yeah
basically I'm trying to put it up now so
you guys can see you know there's these
devices that has pretty much parks offer
take out these research prototypes and
they're talking about bringing this to
mobile and tablet in conjunction with
the X cloud so this way we have more of
a traditional style control because a
lot of people still mail touch controls
are not where
this is gonna bring back the fanny pack
for Allah let's break it to fuzz fuzz
this is very very chatty today about
these topics let's talk about Xbox game
pass to PC at first as well as you don't
do you feel Xbox users are being slide
you know just in general and then
obviously the X cloud prototype stuff
that's coming out it's potentially
coming out for these of mobile and
tablet control devices so the floors
no I mean it's cool that they're looking
for controller implementation because
you know that's when you're using like
say a tablet or a cell phone those
controls are horrible just horrible so
yeah I mean that's good and some people
will use it but at the same time like
I'm staying with the fanny pack remark
yeah I'm exaggerating you know be I'm
joking but at the end of the day like
how am I gonna carry that [ __ ] around I
mean this is that four five it's not
going in my jeans and then these kids
are wearing any jeans now so it's not
good they're gonna have to be wearing
backpacks or something but let me ask
you this fun look acid I know I know you
are the resident og on the panel with me
right so my question to you is obviously
I know your stance on streaming I've
seen it before it's Twitter I know
you're not the biggest fan of this but
my question to you is as a person who
plays Red Dead right and you love this
game and just the option to have the
ability let's just say you know you you
wait yet at Grandma's she doesn't have
you don't got your Xbox one axe with you
you know you went away for you somewhere
else and you got the ability you know
maybe right in the doctor's office at
the DMV just waiting there
no red I don't see myself pulling out a
controller out of anywhere you know look
like the last the last handheld I bought
was the PSP okay and that was the last
one I bought for a reason because I
decided then I don't like handhelds it's
not don't like the one out and about
games like I wait for that you know to
me that's that's that's something like
right gaming is your home line at the
bank playing some red I'm not one of
these toilet sitters to play these games
fair enough I see what you say and all
the Xbox to game pass to peace though I
think I think it's a great option for
people out there don't don't get me
wrong when I'm talking about this stuff
I'm talking about me person uh --then
against anybody else
gamers if you're into sitting on that
toilet plan your guy boring ass wedding
or funeral games go ahead and play your
games life doing life things out and
about allows you to game anywhere anyway
is great I don't care I mean if some
people don't like to touch controls on
their devices yeah then it's a device
they will have for you some people like
like like fauna so he don't want to be
there awkward deep slapping sooo
controllers on the side of his phone in
the street you know that guy but then at
the same time I'm not saying god I had
that Nvidia shield popping it up with
that controller wherever I was at and I
was playing it um so my inhibitions is a
whole lot lower than yours are so I will
definitely 100% take a look see okay if
it's something that can help me game if
I gotta get if we're in a raid or
something and I don't want to stop
raiding yeah but are they going to want
you to stay in the raid
being on that you know well you know we
got rid of those the frauds so at no
point in time we're actually men that
actually have lies fill all the way gay
past the PC do you feel away that uh let
me tell you something if anybody has a
problem with that that's their the
problem alright um it's a natural
progression don't ever think Microsoft
and stop pigeonhole and Microsoft into
this company that only made console
games and games are only supposed to be
on console you are playing your game on
a console that's a choice in your life
if they have played anywhere that means
who did that for you Phil do you want me
to play anywhere you can at any time he
wants those engagement levels through
the roof so in the game cells on PC he
doesn't care if it sells on tablet he
doesn't care if it sells on your phone
he doesn't care and it sells on the Xbox
he doesn't care if you have a problem
with somebody else's gaming that's a
problem with yourself to get to the PC
market to get to the millions and
millions of customers over there yes man
as a business man why not
yes no I agree with everything you said
there King because I do believe in all
that and I think it's great to have all
these options I think what some people
are tired of though is hearing about all
these options and not hearing about
these games I think that's the end of
the day that's what people are really
focusing on so if they had the games
there and all these options were coming
out people wouldn't say too much right
and and and an indifferent response to
that I completely agree with that you
know people do want to see the games but
it also in robot to that there's also we
have to also give credit that when they
do buy studios to try to address that we
have to understand at least action is
being taken to kind of kind of solve the
perceived weakness right as opposed to
them doing nothing and there's no game
use I'm saying and then we're just
sitting there like there's no news of
any trying to acquire games or trying to
you know fix a weakness
there definitely is I mean going after
those studios and everything it's a
great move great rent but yeah time will
tell I want to see what EXO is all about
that's when I absolutely absolutely
addict solve what you feel about the
scarlet controls in the game past a pc
addict let's go I don't care do you not
care about all what about curious though
we don't care about all the cloud
portability being able to be at work
with your mobile phone not gonna switch
you know you just wish stop line stop
don't you do don't you do that in the
low control adapter you that about that
life now I don't really pre-k we very
very rarely even know I don't really you
feel about the PC game SPC unfair fair
don't care I don't care I mean if anyone
didn't see this coming they clearly
don't pay attention okay fair enough
solve need you on both topics when it
comes to like the X cloud stuff like I'm
not this is why I've always been talking
about I'd like some sort of portable
device that they make specifically for
this stuff cuz I'm not big on the split
controller stuff and you know it just
seems it looks weird to me like I'm
rather than the supposed controller
stuff I'd rather just get like something
that attaches to the top of my elite
controller I just put my phone in that
like which is what they showed kind of
an earlier something like that but it's
not a stuff that's just weird yeah I
don't know I don't want that which is
really why we've been talking of this
specific device just for this gotcha
which is which still could be coming
with that suppose it's our first new
coming so exactly right it could be
doing something in that vein so then
that's what I'm looking towards but yeah
I mean you know me like if any chance
that I get to continue my xbox you know
playing outside of the house and yeah
and it's reasonably close to what I'm
used to playing yeah I'm good with that
Neville go so game pastor PC game pastor
PC yeah I was an obvious movie that was
coming I think it's great to continue to
explain expand that ecosystem the people
that may not you know apart from
Microsoft first party stuff haven't you
know if they don't have access system
which is ridiculous everybody has access
system but um what it's interesting to
me is what are the third party games
that are gonna be on game pass it is it
the exact same thing that we're seeing
on console is it gonna be the easy
versions of those games because they
haven't indicated that they've figured
out like perfect software emulation for
360 stuff on PC they haven't said that
per se so it's gonna be interesting to
see if it looks different than what it
does on on on the console right no
obviously you have to play everywhere
with the first party stuff so you have
that on PC already but the third party
stuff is is generally just you know Xbox
and Xbox one and Xbox 360 stuff and na
and OG xbox so right don't forget they
just announced mouse and keyboard so I
mean that was a rumor going around real
quick they were actually in talks with
Turtle Rock Studios trying to buy them
because I think that that might have
some truth because all out of all of a
sudden everything from those valve games
just got reimagined like note and head
and all them and if they bought them and
they got to let the left4dead license
and they're making a sequel do you think
that that's gonna be relevant listen is
it so I always say I've got who I had
this conversation with um you always
have to look at the timing of backward
compatibility announcements because like
we've had a lot of lower bills still
well on from the from the back
compatibility team a lot of this is not
Microsoft's decision a lot of it is the
publisher and a lot of times they try to
do things strategically within a launch
window so if there is potentially a new
left4dead coming out it would make sense
that you now allow Microsoft to put
these on backward compatibility
you get the hype buzzing now you can go
back by the old versions to new ones
coming it's been done strategically with
Bethesda with the Fallout series and
countless other Xbox backward compatible
games that right before the release of
the new version here they come so I
wouldn't be surprised
yeah but you know with all these games
in game paths would they all make it to
PC come over to PC because there are
certain games like Red Dead Redemption
that's in game paths I'm wondering you
know it's never been on PC right you
know fine
this is what I say with that Xbox app is
going to come into play because if
they're telling you that you could play
your Xbox anywhere that is gonna be the
portal in which they get that onto that
PC so don't think is going to be you
know played just right off the PC I
believe if that PC will be their
streaming portal and the game pass will
be streamed onto the the PC you know
yeah you're right and and also we don't
even I mean do we have concrete evidence
that you are gonna have third-party
joints on there are they going to be
directly Microsoft games on this app no
it's gonna be interesting yeah as far as
the thing you know that is the scarlet
project a cloud stuff you know all this
stuff kinda interest me shot the locker
box you know for guys gonna go you know
listen you want to provide options you
know a lot of these phones are extremely
capable we know 4G at minimum was all
you probably kind of need to run these
things and if again if proven to be
seamless
you know it's an option watch out or
just have to interact with you have to
see it before we can make a
determination but I do like the fact
that they are thinking about it because
standard touch controls was never really
a goal for me and any type of controller
base but I would solve I think I'm the
time to probably take the traditional
Elite control with me in that way you
know I'm saying if possible and
hopefully you know they bring this done
things too like TV almost in a way that
a Playstation had attempted to do it
with a Playstation now on as an app on
like a television so this way I'm at
someone's house and it's like they're
not a gamer all I have this my control
in the back I don't even have to have
the X with me or Scarlett or whatever
and I can then gain you know I think
that is very about like I can just go
and think about going to my mom's house
and she doesn't me do some project and I
could be gained help bring about ghazals
so again options to means you know
always a good thing as far as the game
past to PC listen I understand King you
killed it I mean at the end of the day
these are options if you are upset that
the PC is having an option you know
Microsoft wants you to play anyway then
hey get a PC get a PC if you feel that
you know at the end of the day that
they're not taking care of you as an
Xbox gamer then by all means the option
is there and you can play those at the
best fidelity and you know have these
options but I do agree with Fonz the
question is going to be is the full
gamut of game past games available on PC
will they get the back compat titles
will they get a red damn which in theory
has never been on PC with is this red
dead and Rockstar setting something who
knows you know there's a lot of
questions here so I thought it was
interesting time will tell we shall see
but that's all I got anyone else got
anything for we get out of here as
football is raging on all right let's
get into the pole for the Dames get out
of it with the technical breakdowns and
rave reviews received by various media
outlets regarding Red Dead Redemption -
on the Xbox one X is this now the
definitive reason to own or purchase the
X the dances are a no one game doesn't
justify purchasing the Xbox one X B yes
the X is the best place to play
multiplayer or C I don't care
864 P is only s is the place for me that
it's the question those are the choices
please Rock the IOP vote when he goes
out later on tomorrow George a father
really
pleasure to have you back in the room
where can I find people find you and
what do you have going on now the
pleasure was all mine you guys are
amazing awesome honestly my favorite my
favorite gaming podcast they're
revamping I listen you guys every week
if it's not live I listen at work so
don't don't get it twisted you know I
always listen to you guys I love it love
the show and you guys honestly do some
amazing stuff here you're not only in
form but you also entertain like nobody
else so III love it you guys can find me
at Jay Fonzarelli on Twitter and on
YouTube and I'm you know I occasionally
put up videos not very often but
occasionally I do salute outlawed out
locate schoolís I read that I loved it
there this is your movie I had to have
you you know at the end of the day I
know how much you love this franchise I
see I've seen your tweets and um it's
just good to kind of see you justify
like this is your Vova you know you gave
out looks fantastic it's getting rave
reviews even though attic can't stay in
control but at the end of the day it is
really a yeah and that's the thing I
just want to say that I respect other
people's opinions if they don't like a
game I like it so be it same thing goes
for for them hopefully if I don't like
one of their games so be it you know we
all have our opinions out there we can
just you know live with each other get
along you know absolute pleasure Lord
addict the man of his word came through
like a champ
took all these numbers in like it's am
kicking and screaming but he came
through he's holed up you have to
respect that Lord addict what do you
have going on what kind of amplifies you
nothing
[Applause]
any videos coming from you sir well you
get your head back after you bro thank
you for coming to I know you want to
feel well and we appreciate you the
emerging spidey sense you have been
bitten sir
[Laughter]
so the iron bank what is going on look
at the power people find you man you
know you guys can find me playing Red
Dead all week with some game and we
can't play which showing your face now
yeah I try to get in like an hour and a
half an anchor and a Fastback get at me
it took me a second to say yes I'm
intruding on my time well we had a good
combo about the games that was fun but
yeah you know me man and everything else
is in the bushes and so that's done I'm
sorry
AC Odyssey I'm sorry Tomb Raider Bobby
in there the mandolin gang have to deal
with these Red Dead frauds on this
outlaw cowboy ride hey what can I say
the game is brilliant though it's
brilliant for all its you know little
faults here Twitter and a big sovereign
on PSN and Xbox Live no doubt say boss
boo says solve living his best life lord
King the winner of bed the D 2018 you
were in rare for sad where could a five
people find you much
in this new york city streets swinging
from building to building I'm gonna be
on that PlayStation until this is done
then I'm gonna do the DLC and then I'm
gonna go do that guard or walk I'm gonna
I'm just you know what I'm gonna give
this PlayStation a little bit of love
because if this segment has been getting
any love charge those controllers is
pissing me off though um but yeah Kos is
coming
that's king of statues check that out we
soon gonna have a combat talk with the
king shirts in the t-shirt our store we
have some things cooking and I want you
guys to like follow and subscribe to
everybody here I gotta give a shout out
to Lord Fonzarelli cuz I knew when he
was coming he was gonna talk MMA talk
and bring me up to speed I didn't forget
anything that we talked about in the
background and what we're trying to do
with that aspect of it um but yeah
please send me those stuff about that
new fighter so I can get a breast of his
past fights and stuff like that but when
I knew he was here and it's always a
pleasure if I play with him in destiny
any chance I get to have around this a
very good friend cuz he is a very good
friend you know I'm happy and I'm
pleased with it so when I saw you was on
the day besides you know sovereigns
going crazy over the rich I knew that we
was going to get some intellectual
conversation that will be stimulating to
go along with the performing that I was
planning falling into my Spidey trap
[Laughter]
once again Vaughn's men couldn't said it
better like thank you so much for coming
through true friend to the realm true
game the man is passionate please follow
his channel he has some great videos and
again if you want to see some of the
best
intro with nostalgic feel you've got to
be subscribed to Jay Fonzarelli channel
man I'm telling you right now this man
puts you in a place I just like to open
and beat I can listen to that I don't
know where you got that beat effort but
I love that opening
it's a song I like that I heard and I
liked it and then one day I thought man
I need to make an intro and I go what
about that song that song so it just
smooth it has a very nostalgic feel I'll
be bumping up like it's real cool but
your soluti coming out your salute Benna
me was absolutely hilarious Thank You
King Thank You addict that was worth the
price of admission
had he done what was good it was good
obviously you don't say make sure
everybody you hit like and subscribe to
the aisle on the podcast YouTube channel
all the outlets you know we want Spotify
now iTunes SoundCloud Google Play all
that links will be in the description
like I will have all that information
that later tonight with the audio a
shout out to the stream team you got
some stuff coming snarl oh and lady
l-boogie we're gonna have a review
coming out check out the channel on
Tuesday fantastic job at lady LP and of
course lost Naldo and we're gonna have a
new member that hopefully we should be
announcing soon on now and like King
said we got stuff cooking man we got
some stuff also thanks so much for the
support on the red dead giveaway y'all
we definitely our first giveaway really
appreciate it man
the support was tremendous that really
we're gonna be doing more of this stuff
in the very near future so look out for
that we get to a thousand more things
happen so if you're not sub tell your
friends to sub get over here man we just
trying to produce high quality content
and we got some real fun things we got
planned but that's all I got football
has started relate but if anybody got
anything else to say before we get out
of here
alright everybody enjoy this piece